In this lesson, we're going to take a look at reflections
when it comes to baking.
So let's get started.
So first, we want to talk about when to use them.
So reflections are to be used with primary reflective
surfaces, giving them the illusion
of believable reflective materials and substances.
If they aren't used, Unreal will use screen space
reflection as a default. And that's not always
the best way to represent your visuals, especially
when you're baking.
So using the reflection capture elements
creates a more detailed, believable reflection.
And you can find them under Modes, Visual Effects.
The types that can be used are as follows.
We have screen space by default, spherical reflections,
box reflections, and planar reflections.
I'll walk you through some of these
and I'll bring one into Unreal briefly
and we'll get back to the slides so you can see how they work.
So to be able to call them up, we
can simply type in here under Place Actors, the reflection
here, and you'll see we have box reflection, planar reflection,
and sphere reflection capture.
Now sphere for things that are a bit more rounded
or more organic, box for obviously things
a little bit more box in size and shape,
and then, or I should say, this is planar,
box on the top for the size and shape, planar for things
if you like have your body of water
or things that you really need the reflection to be realistic.
And again, this is a baking scenario
and is not needed with Lumen.
Lumen has its own reflectivity properties.
It borrows from ray tracing, but in it,
it also has a boost where it's actually
using global illumination in its reflectivity.
So it's actually pretty great to be able to see that.
Now in here, you can also type in here under Get Content.
You can type reflection, and you'll
see those same ones come in.
You can see here I have a sphere here, reflection capture.
Now this one, I can control its influence radius.
So if I need to make it bigger or smaller,
it actually can help.
And you'll see those highlights show up
on that rock at the distance, and it
shift on the sphere itself.
So this is really up to you how you place it.
And as you place it, Unreal will try to update initially.
And as it does, then you want to make sure
that you're running another reflection capture
build right here.
So let's go back to the slides.
So note again, reflection captures are used for baking
and are not necessary for ray tracing,
but I do highly recommend them because they can help.
So if you do use ray tracing, which
we'll go over in another class, ray tracing
has real-time reflections with no rebaking needed,
but a hybrid of both can be used to help performance.
And visuals, I should add.
So when you use a reflection capture,
you can actually tell ray tracing to lean on them,
like be able to borrow some of that.
Now again, we go into that CVAR in detail
and that breakdown in another course
talking about ray tracing, but I just
wanted to point that out.
So screen space reflections can also
be controlled in the post-process volume.
There you can control the intensity, the quality,
and the roughness.
But keep in mind, it's based on the positioning of your camera.
So if I move my camera around, that screen space
could warp and distort.
And obviously, it's not going to give me fully accurate
reflections.
So the sphere reflection and box reflections, again,
we can control the radius of that.
But you can also load a cube map if you need to by changing
the reflection source type.
This is really up to you.
You can also control brightness as well as the angle.
So this depends if you're loading a source in there.
So you can't load your own if you have a cube map that you
want to load and you want that reflection to represent that.
So another way to be able to adjust your reflections
is if you use in the baking method,
Unreal 4 as well as Unreal 5 supports the planar reflections.
So planar reflections are expensive, keep in mind.
And some of your effects may not show up in it.
So if you're using older Cascade or Niagara,
they may not show up in the reflection.
But it does give you accurate reflections.
It's just kind of a good way to do it.
So if you're using a real-time camera,
it's just kind of expensive.
Again, when you can to try to use Lumen.
And this is a fallback if you needed
to use it for a particular shot or necessary part
of a lower end game and you're noticing that the Lumen isn't
quite what you're looking for.
So these are just informative areas
that you can think of that you can add to your scene
if you had to use baking.
So just keep these things in mind.
Be very deterministic and don't rule out Lumen.
But this is also, I want to put this in your screen.
So if you're using a camera, you
can use the Lumen as a secondary to be able to have an option
if you need to.
So again, we have scenarios for it.
Using the sphere for more spherical or rounded surfaces.
You can get away with using it for hard flat surfaces that
are more box-shaped.
But you have to make sure that the spherical reflection is
pretty close to the point of interest.
So if you're using a camera, you can use the Lumen as a secondary
to have an option to have a more spherical reflection.
And start to break down to become a spherical type
of reflection or warping.
And we want to avoid that.
You do have building quality, which
we mentioned in the earlier part of the course,
where you can control reflection capture resolution.
So if you're going to use them, try
to keep them relatively high if you can.
We lower those a bit.
But 2048 and 1024 is good for more PC games,
centric, or maybe even final pixel.
But definitely can support ray tracing better
to have a higher quality.
Tips and tricks here.
Reflections are used for light baking.
Again, not calculated in a ray-traced scenario
because you don't have to rebuild them.
But it can add some detail and give a little optical illusion
to it.
It actually is a fallback.
You can think of it that way for ray tracing.
Uses that data that that spherical reflection capture
comes into play and allows you to get a better quality
and bounce in your reflectivity.
You'll see here a few more tips.
And again, keep your resolution high,
especially if you're making your own.
Here's another link that gives you a little bit more
in depth than that if you dive into it.
And that's about it with this course.
In the next course, we'll look at view modes and visualizers
when it comes to Unreal and analyzing your scene.